uh welcome back Sam Smith is back again
with more attention-seeking vulgarity uh
they're never one to do things quietly
in recent years we have to remember call
him they there them even though there's
only one of them I remember the latex
balloon at the Brits
but they've taken things up a notch
haven't they with a new Global tour
criticized as hyper-sexualized and
satanic and apologize if you're easily
offended for what you're about to see
nature
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah exactly well joining me now is
comedian James Barr and best-selling
author of The Madness of crowns Douglas
Murray well Douglas let me start with
you uh I don't get this Sam Smith thing
it just seems like every week he
deliberately babe I'm sorry they even
though there's only one of them
why why is Sam Smith today no please do
address Douglas first but I just need to
come why is that's how they identify
that why is it why is one person they
because that's how they identify why
have I got to go along with it because
they've asked you to so what no one's
asked me even the pope respects people's
pronouns now I don't have to respect
anybody's pronouns well that's fine as
long as your decision my pronoun is
hottest man in the world yeah well I'm
happy to call you that some may disagree
but yeah if that's what you are cool I
will address you as the hottest man in
the world throughout the entire
throughout the entire okay let's stick
to that Douglas let's come back to you
uh you don't have to come with the
hottest man in the world even if you're
thinking
um Sam Smith
to me he's just on an Ever deteriorating
campaign to be as vulgar and defensive
as he possibly can am I missing
something
uh he's doing what pop stars have done
for decades which is trying to shock as
a means to get publicity and of course
it's pretty successful I mean we're
talking about him at the moment uh but
it's it's striking that it's sort of
very unoriginal I mean all the stuff
he's doing the sort of over sexualized
stuff the sort of satanic stuff Madonna
did this 40 years ago
um uh you know pop stars have done this
and more for decades now uh I think the
only thing that Sam Smith has got sort
of going of him on this and the thing
actually is making people notice him on
this is that first of all he keeps sort
of throwing these bollards in the way of
everyone by changing his alleged gender
all the time here okay he came out some
years ago
he came he came out as many years ago as
gay and then he said he was actually uh
gender queer and then he said he was
non-binary and he said he didn't know
what it meant of course he didn't
because there's no such thing they but
he's he said that they were going to uh
he said that he thought he was gender
Quinn he didn't know what it meant but
he said that he would explain it someday
when he did know and I thought so I
think if you're going to make everyone
else distort the language you should
know what you're talking about first so
he does that to get publicity obviously
and the other thing he does is he does
this sort of
um you know like taking all his clothes
off stuff and and the thing that makes
it different from other people is that
when oh I don't know Justin Timberlake
or Rihanna or someone stripped down they
do so because they look good like their
bodies look good Sam Smith is like pudgy
and very ugly and so people look at it
and he looks ridiculous and the problem
is is he's saying don't ridicule me but
it's hard not to ridicule people when
they present this right now
are you talking about it on that point I
completely agree why say don't ridicule
me when you deliberately make yourself
look ridiculous no that is disgusting
that is a completely disgusting well
it's disgusting yeah we do find it
there's no what you're saying is why
we're allowed to find him no you are not
keep coming depending on what people
look like all the time if they're going
to dress like that on a stage in front
of millions of people around the world
absolutely I can thank you for getting
the pronoun correct I really appreciate
that listen Douglas yes you did have you
cool have you called me mine hottest man
in the world because according to
someone and yourself
um listen the pope recently said they
completely accept every gender identity
and that everyone is a children why
should anyone be compelled to use a
pronoun from someone's identity three
times in three years
it's very important to note that other
pop stars have done this including Lewis
Capaldi who recently did a campaign
where he was naked on a billboard and
there were nowhere near as many vile
comments at Lewis Capaldi's body the
only reason you can't see any reason
there's a problem for Sam doing it is
because you aren't happy with his gender
identity because it makes you feel no I
don't care about his General identity I
just don't feel I can be compelled to
use pronouns I don't care about that's
fine don't use them if you don't want to
it's wrong you just told me I had to no
I think you should but if you don't want
to so I don't have a decision peers shut
up it's on Modest man alive right okay
right so it's changing your name now
you're no longer my body about Sam Smith
is is just an orgy of in my view
narcissistic self-indulgent deliberately
shocking stuff and Douglas has got point
he doesn't he looks terrible okay so why
would you do this you're friends with
Ozzy Osbourne right yeah Ozzy Osbourne
ate a bat's head on stage that could be
considered vulgar I mean he basically
Osbourne never did anything like this he
started the covered pandemic he can't
seriously think about Sam Smith getting
there serious you think what we're
looking at here is actually anything
other than ridiculous no I think it's
absolutely fantastic really yeah I do I
think it's brilliant I think it's sexy
if you think that's sexy that is the
thing what we're looking at right now is
sexy yes I do yeah seriously would you
shag it
did you say
well there's a question yeah absolutely
I would have sex
because it sounds like you're a little
bit too obsessed with them if I'm honest
with you no no no I can assure you I'm
not I know what I like and I don't like
fat blubbery show-offs who look hideous
dressed in Lacy pants with their fats
spilling out everywhere and doing it in
front of as many people as possible to
gain attention I just don't find that
sexy and old-fashioned
why on Earth are you friends with beers
Morgan
well you'll notice that you'll notice of
course that pierce hasn't appeared on
this show naked with nipple tassels
there isn't it yes again I want to quote
the pope again because the pope has done
this documentary are you a Catholic do
you think we're not but I think
so the pope said that to express
yourself sexually is a richness and
anything that detracts from real sexual
expression lessens you and depletes that
richness but he's not doing this for
sexual expressions
just go back to clutching your pearls
um Douglas are we look are we misreading
the room here are there millions of
young people around the world watching
this thinking he's the hottest thing on
a stage anywhere in the world right now
and we should just get used to it
uh no no I don't think so at all uh uh
and no gay guys I know are attracted to
this everyone thinks it's just kind of
ugly and stupid and it's attention
grabbing and much more I I think Sam
Smith's a person of limited Talent
myself I don't much care for his voice
but the point is is that of course he
just kind of goes around and tries to
make headlines and as I say he's pretty
successful at doing that uh but I don't
think anyone finds it sexy I don't know
any woman who finds it sexy I don't know
any gay man who finds it sexy most gay
men I know are attracted to men because
they're men Sam Smith by the way is he's
always trying to cop off with people
like Tom Daly and things I don't think
you can speak simple gay men to be
honest those are pretty much your own
words from things I've heard you say
before you can't speak for an entire
community no no I don't I don't try to I
don't believe there's any such thing as
a gay community or an lgbtqia plus I
think actually if you think this show is
effective or anything onto my stand-up
show because compared to that Sam
Smith's tour is a love letter to
Christianity and Jesus really so I'll
see you at my tour starts tomorrow I did
it I I didn't know you were touring but
good luck with that thank you yeah you
know what James best of luck with the
tour you're never going to persuade me
and clearly not Douglas either that Sam
Smith is anything other than an
attention seeker because but this whole
debate is attention seeking isn't being
an artist about attention seeking it
could be but when you're just going to
that kind of length just to be
deliberately slobishly offensive I think
it's unacceptable you're doing what you
would say islavishly offensive you're
doing that right now by saying vulgar
things about Sam Smith and deliberately
but I'm not wearing a seat enough it
doesn't matter
and send me naked it's like and once
again if you act in a vulgar way you
should expect people to be vulgar about
you I think that's the point if you're
going to do what he does it's been like
Madonna you know when she says stop
objectify me what else are we supposed
to do with them given that all she ever
does is demand we objectively you know
what you're both CIS white straight man
you can carry on I'm not assist anything
right
what did you just say if you just want
to both be when I was born
lately
wait a second what did he just say what
did you call us repeat it says you were
both I can't remember to be honest I
think you said okay why don't you shut
up
I I think you said we're both CIS white
straight men first of all I am white
secondly I am a man thirdly I've been
out and gay my entire adult life which
is about 25 years now
I was I was out as gay when you were
still prancing around talking about
whether or not you were so do be quiet
do stop judging other people and if I
owe you mean judging other people
I'm sorry I got your sexuality wrong no
if I were you I would do the tiniest bit
of research before opening your mouth
you're embarrassing yourself that's
probably why people would I don't think
so all right embarrassing yourself
gentle shame to the queen you know what
I tell you who's really embarrassing
them yourself
herself themselves whatever Jesus is Sam
Smith and on that note we'll leave it
thank you both very much for a picture
of sexy Sam
feeling very harmonious evening